ces 2021 kicked off today but it looked
a lot different because of the pandemic
everything is virtual and there's no
in-person convention events
here in las vegas and that's really
hitting a lot of local businesses hard
as orco mana explains they're coming up
with other ways to try and make money
the all digital ces 2021. ces
2021 is all online due to the covet 19
pandemic the annual trade show which
normally happens in las vegas
had more than 170 thousand attendees
last year
the lvcva says that equaled an almost
300 million dollar economic impact
a lot of that benefiting local
businesses it's definitely a struggle
but with no in-person events this time
around jennifer folk with altitude color
technology says
times are tough they usually create
custom prints for backdrop signs and
tablecloths for ces
but they found new business alternatives
including with the construction industry
we've been able to do some work for them
with their wooden signs signs changing
directional signs now opening
just a lot of those pamela howitt with
local catering company divine events
says they typically make around three
hundred thousand dollars for the whole
week of ces
so to get at least some revenue they've
started a different kind of delivery
service
we're mainly doing things like
deliveries for companies that are
deemed essential work with essential
workers so
that's a big part of it the lvcva is
also feeling an impact it finished the
nearly one billion dollar convention
center expansion in december
just in time for ces but it sits empty
and with the future of conventions in
vegas unclear everyone has just one wish
for ces
2022 we're all waiting for it to come
back orco mana 8 news now
now the businesses we spoke to hope
distribution of the vaccine will mean
conventions will return
sooner rather than later but that still
might not be till
maybe the summer or probably the fall